thank you very much for joining us i'm
john langler for the first time in
nearly a year
elementary schools across the valley
have children on campus
today marks the first step by clark
county school district to get all of its
students in class during the pandemic we
have team coverage for you this
afternoon bianca holman caught up with
parents
as they adjust to hybrid learning but we
start with hector mejia with a midday
update from superintendent dr jesus jara
hector
hey there and the superintendent said he
wants every parent to know that they
are following the recommendations made
by the cdc and the southern nevada
health district inside and outside the
classroom
this is wengert elementary school in the
east valley where the principal tells us
just about 37 percent of their students
chose to return to campus for hybrid
learning
that turns out to about 121 students in
total
the principal added they have an
additional 30 minutes of instruction
here to help students who may need to
catch up
ccisd has previously reported a slump in
grades across the district during
full-time distance learning
and earlier in the morning ccsd held an
event with superintendent dr
jesus jarrah along with state
superintendent joan ebert
as kids in grades pre-k through third
returned for the first time in almost a
year
a lot of excitement one mother told us
the biggest challenge was learning the
online system
vanessa rodriguez says she had to
shuffle her
work schedule around to teach her second
grader how to read
i'm excited for him i mean this is just
the first step but
i mean we're getting closer so hopefully
it returns back to normal soon
i talked to him and let him know mask on
all the time you know follow the rules
and
that way everything could just proceed
to normal it's going to be a challenge
i'm going to have half my class virtual
and then half my class in front of me at
the same time so i'm expecting that to
be a little bit of a challenge
ccsd is operating about 1600 bus routes
buses will only run at half capacity
that's about 28 students on board
students will be paid spaced out while
riding and drivers will
load buses from back to the front and
then students
will get off front to back to avoid too
much crossover so
be sure to watch out for students as
they walk to school or
as they walk home once the bell rings
reporting in the east valley hector
mejia
8 news now